>> Tucker: HILLARY CLINTON
FAILED THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
TWO YEARS AGO BUT SHE HAS BEEN
DETERMINED TO REMAIN IN THE
PUBLIC EYE EVER SINCE.
NOW THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
EDITORIAL BOARD IS FED UP WITH
IT IN AN OPINION PIECE.
BOARD MEMBER MICHELLE COTTLE
COMPLAINS ABOUT CLINTON MASTER
CLASS.
AND SHE CLAIMS SHA SHE IS
DELUDING THE PARTY MESSAGE.
IN SHORT, HILLARY PLEASE GO
AWAY.
AND DAVE RUBEN HOST OF "RUBEN
REPORT" AND JOINS US TONIGHT.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> Tucker: ONE OF THE
BENEFIT TO BEING IN LOS
ANGELES BECAUSE YOU ARE ON THE
SET.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF HILLARY
CLINTON?
SHE STILL IS THE STANDARD
BEARER OF THE PARTY, ISN'T
SHE?
THE LAST NOMINEE.
>> THE LINE ABOUT THE CIVILITY
WE CAN NO LONGER BE CIVIL WITH
THE POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
THINK ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS.
WORD IT DIFFERENTLY.
WE SHOULD BE UNCIVIL?
THAT IS WHAT SHE IS SAYING.
HUNT THEM DOWN IN ELEVATORS GO
TO THEIR JOB, STOP THEM ON THE
ROAD?
WHERE DOES IT GO?
WHAT WE HAVE IS WE CAN DO THIS
EVERY NIGHT, YOU, TUCKER, CAN
ARGUE WITH SOMEONE ABOUT
SOMETHING POLITICAL.
IT DOESN'T GET VIOLENT.
YOU WRAP IT UP AT THE END OF
THE DAY.
YOU GO HOME AND DO IT AGAIN
THE NEXT DAY.
CIVILITY IS ALL WE HAVE.
THEY ARE MAKING IT VERY CLEAR.
THIS IS SOMEONE ON THE LEFT MY
WHOLE LIFE.
I NEVER VOTED -- ONE TIME IN
MY LIFE I VOTED FOR A
REPUBLICAN, MIKE BLOOMBERG IN
HIS THIRD TERM IN NEW YORK
CITY LONG TIME AGO.
HAZY REPUBLICAN SITUATION.
I SAY THIS AS SOMEONE TRYING
TO CALL IT OUT AS I CONSIDER
MY SIDE FOR A LONG TIME.
GUYS, LET'S REIN IT BACK IN.
THIS IS DANGEROUS.
>> Tucker: I WONDER IF SHE
DOES.
>> I THINK THEY REALIZE THEY
LOST CONTROL OF THE PARTY.
THE CLINTON MACHINE DOESN'T
HAVE CONTROL OF THE PARTY.
AND THE PARTY IS GOING THROUGH
A DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST OR THE
SOCIALIST DEMOCRAT.
WHATEVER THEY WILL DROP THE
DEMOCRAT PAR SOON ENOUGH.
SHE IS TRYING TO GRAB TO MAKE
HER FEEL RELEVANT.
IN A WEIRD WAY SHE HAS TO GET
OUT OF THE WAY FOR THE OTHER
THING TO TAKE OVER.
NOT THAT I THINK THE OTHER
THING IS GREAT.
BUT I THINK THE OTHER THING,
THE MORE FAR LEFT WING OF THE
PARTY IS MUCH WORSE.
>> I WOULD TAKE HILLARY
CLINTON ANY DAY OVER SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE.
>> WE WILL LOOK BACK AND SAY
CLINTONS WERE THE GOOD OLD
DAYS.
I VOTED FOR BILL CLINTON
TWICE.
HILLARY CLINTON, THEY ARE
LOSING CONTROL.
THAT IS WHY ERIC HOLDER WHEN
THEY GO LOW, WE KICK THEM.
OWL OF THE THINGS, THESE ARE
NOT COINCIDENCES.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> THIS IS NOT MAXINE WATERS
FIND THEM AND HUNT THEM DOWN
OR WHATEVER SHE SAID.
AND CORY BOOKER DID THE SAME
THING.
I HAVE SEEN ARTICLES ABOUT
YOU.
FIND TUCKER CARLSON IN A
RESTAURANT.
SO UPSET HE WON'T GO TO A
IF THAT IS WHERE WE ARE AT WE
WILL LOOK BACK AND SAY MAN, WE
HAVE SCREWED UP THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL EXPERIMENT DONE IN
WORLD HISTORY.
>> I AGREE.
>> ABOUT HOW YOU GET DIFFERENT
PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
TO COME TOGETHER AND LIVE
TOGETHER.
WE HAVE DONE IT RIGHT HERE.
IT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S PERFECT
FOR EVERYONE OR THAT THERE
AREN'T RACISTS OR THAT WE HAVE
THE CLASS ISSUES.
AND ECONOMIC ISSUES AND ALL
SORT OF THINGS.
BUT IF WE DON'T PULL BACK THIS
THING, IT WILL BE MUCH WORSE
FASTER THAN ANYONE CAN
IMAGINE.
>> Tucker: TOTALLY RIGHT.
IT'S MORE FRAGILE THAN WE